there have to be things like unions
where people can collectively bargain
for the value of their data this is
essential because if it's each person
against each other person then the price
will collapse on the internet there's
nobody who's on your side and there
needs to be so they can serve that
function they can become the first
advocates if nothing changes then things
just continue to get commoditized and we
get packetized and commoditized the idea
of data dignity to me is profound
because I think it's fundamental to what
the future can look like it is my
pleasure to welcome to Yang speaks the
visionary technologists futurist
philosopher musician Jaron Lanier Jaron
welcome hey thanks for having me so
Jaron you should know I quote you on the
trail or I quoted you when I was running
for president all the time some of your
ideas I think are so important for not
just the future but what we're facing
right now so the idea I quoted most
often was you've written and spoken on
the fact that negative ideas and
sentiment spread more powerfully and
viscerally online through social media
than positive sentiments and that has
very very profound implication yeah
unfortunately at least my understanding
of it is that we're dealing with some
very old and kind of nasty evolutionary
legacies because in the human cognitive
system we have these stupid rapid-fire
systems that we usually call the
fight-or-flight responses which are
coping with danger where we have a like
if we were talking about computers we
talk about them as you know inescapable
low-level subroutines in the operating
system you know they're not just an app
they're they're baked and really deep
and so we have to decide whether to run
or fight
and because the
so deep since the beginning of
civilization people have known that if
you want to get others attention and if
you want to sort of manipulate them
activating this system is one way to do
it but what has never happened before is
we've never had an interactive system
that's constantly measuring people and
optimizing itself to activate these
these old systems in the human being so
what happens is when the whole society
is kind of constantly being prodded by
the algorithms to excite their
fight-or-flight responses and it's not
like anybody at Google or Facebook sat
there and said they wanted to do this
well maybe at Facebook but certainly not
at Google it's just that the algorithm
naturally optimized itself into finding
this thing because it's there waiting to
be found by any adaptive algorithm so
then what happens is you get this
diffuse version of it shifting the
Society's cognition and the diffuse
version I like to call just irritability
and paranoia and so you get you get this
wafting cloud of irritability and
paranoia which then colors everything
and makes people less sane and less able
to deal with reality than they used to
be one of the things you say drives this
and I I think this is also both correct
and profound is the business models of
these companies where you you have
companies that are essentially profiting
off of clicks and engagement for
advertising revenue and so it's not just
that they're tapping into these parts of
our brains that have been hardwired but
then they get rewarded for it yeah yeah
yeah I was around when that happened and
it's it's really a drag it's sort of a
tragedy how it all unfolded way back in
the beginning there were a few ideas
that a lot of people believed in very
intensely everybody wanted to have
perfect socialism online where there
wouldn't be money and everything would
be free everybody wanted to worship tech
entrepreneurs like Steve Jobs as an
example and and just to resolve those
two things was really hard and
only solution anyone ever found was the
advertising model and if it was just
old-fashioned advertising like on TV it
would just it would be no worse than
that was and overall I think that's done
more good than harm although some people
disagree with me but it wasn't
old-fashioned advertising it turned into
this constant measurement and feedback
system this behavior modification system
and that's where we ran into trouble
yeah I think you coined an acronym
around this the the bummer which I
thought was lever it out yeah let's see
if I can remember it behavior of users
modified and made into an empire for
rent yeah I thought that was indeed a
bummer that really summed it up
particularly because the empire that's
being rented or built is being built on
our data like our habits our preferences
what we like what we react to what we
clicked on and you're passionate about
the fact that our data should be ours as
one of the big reforms yeah so this is
something I've been thinking about for
many years and I I'm were convinced than
ever I don't think it's I don't think
it's the only solution we need I don't
think it's like some kind of magic key
to fixing the future but I do think it's
one part of the mix that we definitely
need if you think back on the history of
how people have contributed to
civilization one of the really
interesting high points for me was the
introduction of the idea of quality by
Deming or Six Sigma sometimes it's
called where what you do is you have
people who are working on something
become aware of how what they're doing
is contributing to quality for the
society so that they can take pride on
it instead of being treated like robots
and this is famously how Japan moved
from being a bad manufacturing company
to the best manufacturing company by
making people working on an auto line
for instance aware of how what they did
affected the outcome of the automobile
and listening to them treating them as
human beings but in Silicon Valley
we haven't learned that lesson what we
say is when we get data from people
we're gonna treat it as exhaust that's
always the word oh it's just their
exhaust as if people couldn't contribute
and then we get all this data in that
people didn't know they were
contributing and then we're supposed to
make it useful and algorithms wouldn't
it make more sense wouldn't it be better
wouldn't it just be smarter for people
to understand how their data could be
used to be motivated to earn some money
to make it better to become creative
participants to become to take on some
of the power the decision-making power
of what the ultimate algorithm should do
I mean wouldn't it just make everything
better for this to be more distributed
like this idea of treating people as
mindless exhaustion is like rats in the
maze being like don't worry about it or
Insecta people acting as batteries in
the Matrix movies like it's just stupid
like if the Matrix movies were real the
whole thing would collapse because they
wouldn't have been enough data to run
their AI agents you know like like
people should participate and make good
data like what isn't that a more
sensible it's just more dignified and
they'll make everything better the idea
of data dignity to me is profound
because I think it's fundamental to what
the future can look like like if nothing
changes
then things just continue to get
commoditized and we get packetized and
commoditized so I I agree with you that
there's something fundamental about data
dignity like treating us like not just I
guess vehicles like emitting extra but
as agents as participants as owners in
my mind as renter's of our data if we
decide to share for our convenience yeah
one of the key ideas of data dignity is
that you can't just sell your data you
can only license it you have moral
rights to it kind of like an artist in
France or something like that this is
extremely important because you don't
want to have
some kind of data indentured servitude
what you want to have is and then here's
another idea that might not sound very
Silicon Valley but I think it's really
important there have to be things like
unions where people can collectively
bargain for the value of their data this
is essential because if it's each person
against each other person then the price
will collapse but that's true of
absolutely everything like we when we
think about labor we talk about unions
but the you know supposedly elite
scientists like me who are involved in
Silicon Valley companies we get together
we make corporations we make startups we
also band together to limit the degree
to which we're constantly fighting each
other as individuals it's an absolutely
necessary step to building up a society
so I don't think the people who ordinary
people who make data will join exactly
something like a classical Union we need
something new but it'll have some of the
qualities of the Union well that there
is a massive collective action problem
obviously because if you're an
individual user you're just clicking I
agree I consent and hoping for the best
yeah I mean oh gosh a long time ago I
co-founded as a commission in the EU
that was one of the things that
eventually turned into the GDP are there
big privacy framework and one time I was
in Geneva and I had like two thousand
data lawyers from around the EU and I
said have any of you ever read one of
these agreements that you click on that
wasn't the one you wrote but that's
somebody else wrote and not a single
hand went up like even the lawyers don't
know what they say and so in theory the
GDP are standardized them a bit that I
don't really think it's had much of an
effect cuz the truth is code speaks
louder than law you know that completely
and I think yeah your idea of like a
digital Union for data rights I think is
necessary it's vital because as an
individual you're outgunned government
is decades behind this curve they don't
even understand many of these issues
though I'm happy to say that now certain
states like California
are at least putting laws on the books
to start trying to empower individuals
to a higher degree yeah you know the the
the California data dividend law might
very well be remembered as a key step
along the path to making a workable
future we'll see there's still a lot
that's unknown about how it'll sort out
but it's it's a really interesting
process and for once there are some
people in the loop who understand a few
of these things and I feel like the
different people who have different
opinions are actually talking to each
other so it's it's kind of a bright spot
I love the fact that you've become a
voice for reform of the internet reform
of what these tech companies are doing
with our data because to me it's so
central and you're one of the few people
who can speak authoritative lis about it
because you're one of the godfathers of
the modern internet well hey can I say a
little bit more about these Union like
things please would love it
so sometimes we call the mids for
mediators of individual data that's been
a term used in the academic literature
in the California law they're called
data Trust's if that's I don't know how
similar the California law will be to
the academic ideal we'll see but the
idea of amid it's not just a union that
collectively bargained so that the
prices don't fall to zero it does a few
other things it provides for the very
first time a fiducial service so a
fiducial is somebody who has more power
over a part of your life than you do and
swears an oath to only serve your
interests and not anyone elses and a
good example would be a doctor or a
lawyer or certain certain financial
advisors but there's nothing like that
on the internet on the internet there's
nobody who's on your side and there
needs to be so they can serve that
function they can become the first
advocates
they can become the first complexity
managers so that you can say to them
okay I don't know all these contracts I
don't know all this stuff you figure it
out I've got a name for these
collectives data guild what do you think
I just made it up
no guilt you know I think that that's
actually an interesting one because
guilds are one of the predecessors of
the the medieval guilds were the
societal institution institutions that
were secular and really important to
holding everything together and they
definitely were precursors for
institutions not just unions but also
benevolent organisations and other other
societal structures are really important
in the emergence of decent modern
democracies one of the things you hit on
that's really powerful is that our data
becomes much more valuable if we
willingly participate because right now
you can only do certain things
anonymously and that if I'm actually a
partner in this then the value shoots up
and I may be completely happy with that
if I'm actually sharing in that value as
opposed to right now at all getting
passed around without my knowledge
jaren you you've identified so many of
like the massive massive problems that
are killing us really so so we started
by you talking about how the Internet is
making us essentially more irritable and
paranoid and and then we which you know
you can't really argue with I mean that
that's happening and then we agree that
the business models are helping fuel
that dynamic because they thrive on this
war for attention how do we need to
reform the business models so that that
some of these companies are also fueled
by
decency and reducing the negative
effects on our democracy culture society
discourse you know you name it because
it's affecting everything well if I had
my way the behavior modification
business model would be outlawed and and
you can drop write line about
to be specific about what that means the
use of an algorithm to measure human
behavior in order to customize content
for the benefit of a third party who's
paying that chain of events you can
define because you can see where the
information and the money move in the
system and that should be outlawed that
should be considered a corrupt and and
just bad model and then as an
alternative to it there are a number of
excellent ones and the most obvious one
is just charging people for whatever you
have and then also paying them for what
they give and really turning it into
part of capitalism instead of this weird
pseudo stealth socialism so Google and
Twitter and Facebook would ask you to
pay subscription and people don't mind
that they pay crazy amounts I mean
they're they do it for Netflix and
things like Xbox and all kinds of stuff
I mean the subscription model works
there have to be allowances for those
who can't afford it but that can work
too I mean I I really don't you know
what might help with this it sounds like
it sounds like universal basic income
might be a helpful precursor to this
well we should talk about that so shot
the thought is I interrupted you there
well you know so the thing is I don't
believe that markets always work I think
there are market failures and I think
markets are technology like any other
and they have to be tweaked and used
well and there's there's no such thing
as a perfect technology but when they
work they work and so I it's very
strange that Silicon Valley as it's
grown up has been kind of anti market
and that everyone's expected to do this
sort of pseudo socialist barter thing
and it's silly I mean we have this
terrible fear that people wouldn't pay
for Google or Facebook but I think they
would I mean it might take a while it
might take a generation actually what
you're saying and I'm saying is that
we're already paying we're just like
paying under the rug we're paying much
too high a price we're paying we're
by loss of dignity and and seeing our
society darkened by weird paranoia and
irritability so the price is very high
but it's not direct it's it you don't
see the immediate connection yes I love
it this is it this is like this
incredibly expensive negative
externality cloaked in the guise of it
being cost free yeah it's really it's
really funny cuz it's almost like a dorm
room level idea of like oh yeah we'll
make everything free you know it's it's
it's it's silly and yet it still has
hold of some of these giant companies
but I want to give you a thought
experiment and this has to do this gets
us closer to the question about you bi
what if in the future robots and AI
programs could do everything so there
was no task that a human needed to do
anymore alright so then of course the
classic question is does that mean that
the humans starve or does that mean that
the humans thrive right and so obviously
what we will never get there 100% but if
we get closer to it even by a small
degree we don't want it to increase
human suffering we wanted to increase
human thriving right and so but at that
extreme at that asymptotic extreme where
is the value coming from in the society
and obviously the only way that robots
and IA is can function is if they have
data and if they're adapting towards
goals and those have to come from people
by definition if the society has meant
for people at all at all at all and so
therefore the data from people even if
it's only in the form of expressing
tastes or desires is the fuel that runs
that future and has to be considered the
most valuable resource and that's that's
a strange way of thinking we're not used
to thinking of thought itself or desire
as a form of labour and I don't want us
to think that way in all cases because
that could become dismal in its own way
of making people into sort of
desiring machines of certain some kind
of absolute consumerist hell or
something but if we want to have a
future for employment and we want
employment to be real and based on
things that people really offer allowing
that data is a form of labour gives us a
way to create legitimate employment for
a large part of the society maybe not
all of it but I think it it's it's a
this and this is what we call data
dignity I think it's a way to imagine
that more raba
rope more robots mean more jobs instead
of less jobs and I think it's logically
consistent and I think the numbers work
out and I think it's not an idea opposed
to ubi
but it might be that the future will be
one in which there's both ubi and data
dignity and people kind of find their
way to some mix of them you know it
reminds me of something that Albert
Vanger the investor talks about time is
the new money and it sounds like that
that was one of the things that you're
describing where like you can define
work and value creation through simply
what we choose to do with our time yeah
I mean I at a certain point we're seeing
limbers of that future already for
instance influencers are people who
figured out how to get paid just for
being human and living right and some
kind of a more though I will say I guess
I get the sense they work very hard to
stage those photos yeah I mean I I admit
I had to kind of suppress some sort of
gag reflex when I brought up that
example but you know one of the things
about trying to think about economics
and the future is that you have to be
how can I put this you have to be very
tolerant of the variations of how people
think and feel it can't be all about
your own values and so I I you know
basically if an influencer on Instagram
or something can do well I always
celebrate people's success unless it's
directly cruel and which it occasionally
is but what I'd rather do is try to find
the parts of it
give us hope for the future and what I
can see there is that the influencers
are serving as prototypes for what I
hope will eventually be a better sort of
organized or unionized movement where
people share and hedge their risks and
become somewhat responsible for each
other in order to promote quality and
all the other things I talked about but
essentially yeah influence in itself
should be a paid thing and there's no
reason why it shouldn't be much broadly
paid as there's more and more AI and
automation and robotics in the future
yes the world of abundance as opposed to
the the world of scarcity that we assume
[Music]
so I just want to go back to some of
your big reforms number one is you get
rid of the algorithm that feeds us
pieces of content for a profit that that
would be a very big deal and then you
make it so that we own our data possibly
through these intermediaries that know
that no you know quote-unquote unionize
on our behalf and then we share in that
value and profit and then we change the
business models of these massive social
media companies and Google and the rest
of them so that there's actually value
changing hands which ends up changing
their incentives their practices in ways
that help us as opposed to hurt us did I
get those three big reforms more or less
right yeah pretty much if I can just
make some very slight adjustments I
don't believe in evil algorithms my
problem with the algorithm is that it's
for the benefit of a third party who's
paying if you can use some of these
behavior mod algorithms with full
transparency for your own benefit if you
want to try to change your own behavior
I have no objection obviously so the
real problem is that third third party
payment and benefit like the algorithm
has to serve you it can't serve somebody
else that make that make sense so in
other words if I'm like hey you
like I'm trying to quit smoking or I'm
trying to do something yeah like you
know improve my consumption of jaren's
podcasts yeah I think it would be a
mistake to go down a path of having
algorithm police that try to ban certain
algorithms what I think it's absolutely
reasonable to have police who ban
illegitimate and hidden transactions
that are manipulative so like if if
somebody's paying your broker to benefit
them instead of you that should be
illegal on the other hand the particular
algorithm the broker uses should not be
illegal what the illegal part should be
the falsified Allegiance understood so
there is absolutely no problem with
Netflix telling me what to watch next
you know I in my own sense right now
Netflix is on the good side of the line
there's occasional things on Netflix
that bugged me but I feel like they're
just doing it out of osmosis from their
neighbors in Silicon Valley occasionally
the Netflix algorithm seems to lead you
to some of their more paranoid and
low-budget silly things and I think
that's not in their financial interest
it's just that it's the standard
practice and people are just used to it
so in engineers move between companies
it just kind of travels with them of
that even anybody considering why so as
long as no one's profiting unbeknownst
to me from what the algorithms feeding
me it's okay so presumably Netflix isn't
getting more money based upon my
basically what Netflix wants you to do
is keep paying and that seems to me to
be a reasonable business model like it's
a transaction for value and it might not
be perfect and there might be occasional
silly things that happen but overall
it's it's okay it's not destroying
civilization it seems like a reasonable
traditional proven way to do things as a
business you pay for service and you
stop paying if you don't want the
service it's so an example so an example
of something that would not be okay
would be if like I was served
something from a third-party advertiser
like as happens on YouTube routinely is
that correct or no yeah so the YouTube
algorithm so this is a bit controversial
YouTube will say it isn't so I've done
my own experiments and it appears to be
so but I haven't done them in sufficient
numbers to feel like I could publish the
results but most people who look at this
report that if the YouTube
recommendation engines just recommends a
sequence of videos to you whether it
knows you or not it seems to after some
usually like seventeen hops land you in
some sort of weird paranoid dark
territory and seventeen steps towards
Hell by YouTube say yeah that's right
that's right
so more steps than Dante had but you
know and so if YouTube was a paid
service I really think that effect would
go away because their interest would
stop being keeping you hooked which is
keeping you paying and keeping you
paying is a very different motivations
different you're right watching that's
so deep I loved it so much that you'd I
think that's a great illustration that
people understand are the different
dynamics you know one of the things
that's interesting about money is it has
a kind of of course it can corrupt
people and bring out the worst and the
pursuit of money is the root of all evil
and all that and that's that that
couldn't be so but there are also times
when it can kind of help clarify a
situation for instance when in in the
last centuries as people started to
organize labor movements and started to
work instead of demanding the ability to
earn absolutely as much money as
possible working as hard as possible
they negotiated free time weekends and
holidays yeah I'm with family and as
part of the benefit package even though
it probably cost some money and that's a
very interesting thing like once you
once you can look at your choices as an
adult with everything revealed and
without any sneakiness people actually
tend to make better choices and so I
think what would happen is YouTube as a
business would care less about
this addictive quality and more about
just getting paid and then people using
the YouTube wouldn't expect to sit there
like on a drip watching recommended
videos but instead would say hey I'm
paying for this I demand to see
something good like you do on Netflix
and they'll be complaints if they don't
it just seems like a healthier
arrangement on both sides I think
everybody would feel better I know
you've been fighting for these changes
for a while now like how do you see that
fight unfolding yeah you know it's a
generational effort I mean the thing
that I kick myself over again and again
is I keep on wondering if back in the
80s or 90s if I'd screamed a little
louder it somehow been more skillful if
I could have helped steer this thing a
little bitter because I was I was in a
few crucial junctures where some things
went wrong in my view and I sometimes
wonder if I was just a little too polite
or something put that pressure on
yourself man these things are like
freaking like you know you know at this
point we have this crazy situation where
the you know the the world has aligned
itself around these bummer information
systems to two significant degree not
absolutely and totally but you know
there's a lot of it and people often
bring up to me well what about the old
media like Fox News or whatever that has
but the problem is that even that is
being colored and guided by the Boomer
machine what happens is memes or
different tropes plans of attack talking
points get bored through the Boomer
machine through this process of
algorithmic amplification and then
they're turned into old fashioned
broadcast on Fox and other channels so
the first time I tweeted something and
then it popped up on cable news I was
like wow yeah so we have a we have a job
to do now and it's not going to be easy
I mean
but I thinks do you change and I one
thing I noticed is that a lot of if you
keep track of the number of former high
executives or founders from Facebook who
publicly renounced what Facebook does
it's really become a long list I mean
it's almost not news anymore the tough
thing about the CERN is like when you
see here that like I appreciate it I'm
friends with some of those people but
what you what you sense is that like
Facebook has become this historic
money-making machine and then enough
people made enough money where they can
step out and be like [ __ ] it like now I
can like you know throw rocks at you and
I'm worth millions of dollars so like
nothing bad can happen to me at this
point like you know the stock bested I
mean I'm grateful to those people but
but that is like the sense you have and
I am glad I mean they could probably
make more money if they still went along
with it and kept their mouths shut
I know some of them as well and I I find
them to be sincere you know and and I I
was actually a funny thing to me is that
a few of them and I'm thinking of Sean
in particular but there's some others
too who have kind of backfilled their
memories to say well actually we were
evil geniuses at the time but now I
renounce that evil that evil plan that
we've hatched but I was there I need
some of them at the time they were
getting in I don't think they actually
knew what they were doing no no you know
I agree with you it's not like they
weren't like malevolent you know it's
like building this thing and you know
like you you make a choice that seems
perfectly fine at a certain size and
scale and then you know you can't
foresee some of the effects over time
yeah I agree I think that's what
happened I think this thing is mostly a
sort of giant farce rather than an
intentional conspiracy or anything well
one thing we're going to be fighting
alongside you on is trying to activate
people's data rights we're going to be
announcing the initiative in that
direction
please consider me a friend and Ally in
your work
jaren because I think you have so much
to offer your vision of the internet
would make the world so much better and
it's a vision that we need to make
happen because the alternative is
disastrous okay so I have a question for
you
do you remember when earlier this year
we were looking at each other for like a
minute but you weren't sure if you
recognized me and you decided it wasn't
me
what was this other colbert's oh yes yes
it was I I was like like that dude looks
a lot like yeah I play in the band on
the Colbert show with Jon batiste and
stay human when I'm in New York which
obviously hasn't been lately because of
you know the pandemic but yeah I mean I
was I was playing in the band and I
I said to John hey I want to go say hi
to that guy and he was saying no man
that's a tough band to be and it's like
he doesn't go easy on us so I was I was
being worked so I'm so glad that you
raised that because I was like man maybe
I'm just like you know I mean you're a
pretty distinctive looking guy but now
that's actually me yeah I put it past
you man I mean like you as as late night
musician makes more sense than there is
like a doppelganger of you walking
around so I could have put you two
together well look man
thanks for being there and I think I
think your contribution and running was
really profound because it's it got the
national conversation to be about our
real future decisions rather than about
symbols and identity and kind of this
endless churn of hopeless stuff and I
well thank you it's yeah and it really
isn't that often I mean I don't want to
be overly cynical about this but it
isn't often that a national politician
brings a new idea into
the stage and starts a conversation
about something real that needs to be
talked about it's like how often does
that happen I don't know I mean rare
it's rare well thank you and one thing I
think is awful is that it takes someone
to run for president for us to talk
about some of these issues I mean what
the hell is that it's really sad how
behind the times our public discussion
and our politicians are thank you so
much Aaron you what you're like a true
visionary and we are going to fight for
your vision of the Internet for all of
our sakes please do consider me a friend
and Ally and anything you do okay man
and I'm sure you have a remarkable
future ahead and I congratulate you and
celebrate you and I wish you the very
warmest successful
[Music]